I almost got in a fight on the way here
do you know that Oh Wyatt this [ __ ]
guy was driving his bike and I he was
coming a little citrate no he's riding
bike a [ __ ] I could tell by his face
he was a [ __ ] I was like you riding
a bike that's old you probably stole
your [ __ ]
Hera's all [ __ ] up guy yep white guy
about my age maybe a little younger
homeless no but a [ __ ] you know just
a general [ __ ] you go in there and
he's got he's got a he's my age and he's
got some ramen noodles and a futon and
he's got a [ __ ] mangy dog he never
walks always told me you know that guy
he smells like mothballs all the time
[ __ ] man who knows now he's just a
[ __ ] yeah one of those guys
everybody think him was and he [ __ ]
is crossing the street you say get a job
now he's crossing the street and I go
well you're not even crossing yet I'm
gonna pull I'm gonna I'm gonna come home
from yeah yeah and you know I knew he
goes you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
sure and I stopped and I went I looked
at him and I went you wanna start me up
[ __ ] you
oh now when I defense when I pop my [ __ ]
the [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I went [ __ ] you
and I never do that cuz he's crap I
don't give a [ __ ] about that guy crazy I
don't know why but I got mad at him I
went [ __ ] you
oooh I stopped and looked at me and I
looked at him and I went do so why'd ya
anyway huh his face tighten up and he
kept and I kept driving cuz I'm brave
and then he I saw him yell at me
afterwards I was like that way oh yeah
gave him the old bird and I never do
that either I don't know what got into
me
I became I got sucked in his energy
because the whole bird thing is like so
efficient and I went like that in the
car yeah so those eyes right here to
shoot up the place
oh not only get mad on the rhodium or no
road rage do you ever get mad on the
road I'm never I'm til now I'm tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
- Tom okay what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]